hello reject nation Greg Alba here John
here at the time we are uploading this
video the skyscraper trailer might have
dropped nose anyway we're gonna watch
the honest trailer for star wars the
spin-offs the holiday special and more
oh boy I'm not gonna lie I have not seen
the holiday special and missing out a
lot of the other spin-offs you've seen
the holiday special yeah yeah yeah I've
seen all of it special
well we're gonna give a page from the
day shout out to totally jumbled today
you seem like you're doing well seem
like you're doing healthy I wanted to
shout you out because I know you're a
huge huge Star Wars fan matter of fact I
never do a google hangout with you you
have an entire bookshelf right behind
you full of a bunch of Star Wars books
linked by fan of hose I think you've
read one of them so you kind of remind
me of Ron Burgundy just a dude with a
large library and hasn't even peeked
through some of the books you are a real
Star Wars fan oh yeah and I'm happy to
shout you out my friend Hannah I love
you
TV trailer before sila milks your
nostalgia for the original trilogy dry
discovered the recited must have took
everything you loved about the old Star
Wars movies and gave you something
different I have never seen any of that
Kiko terror anything of crap with
caravan of courage the Eva Oh before the
other Ewok movie but after the movie
that was 30 percent a walk embark on an
adventure with no one's favorite
unblinking murder tears as they team up
with another creature that's better in
small doses a kid together they'll
search for her missing parents with her
brother mace a Skywalker knock off with
the hair of Luke and the acting of
Anakin
and of course I think
[Music]
whoa Darwin ceases that Disney bound
really early huh
appear event of courage as Muhammad then
get ready cuz battle of endor is Game of
Thrones without question the darkest
Star Wars movie ever made where most of
the Ewoks are slaughtered in the opening
scene the climate's whole family is
Massacre she's killed a dragon and has
to spend the rest of your life getting
yelled at by Wilford Brimley Wow let's
rip someone for life holy crap this is a
Captain phasma prequel isn't it yeah be
cool but those are just warm-ups for the
main event watch the original Star Wars
trilogy lose its final trait of dignity
in the Star Wars Holiday Special
there any magic so bad George Lucas
wanted to destroyed forever and that guy
made Attack of the Clones sit through
this vaguely Star Wars TV variety show
where the only ID is the level of drugs
they were on when they wrote it yeah
it's a song from Mos Eisley cantina
owner Bea Arthur just
[Music]
I saw from 70 soft-rock
titans Jefferson Starship
[Music]
or a saw from Princess Leia while
Harrison poured regrets all of his life
choices they were yeah that's the face
of a man who has a really bad feeling
about this talent sections enjoy a tiny
scrap of story tying it all together
yeah Chewie has to get home to his
family planet
Bala and lucky for life day which is
like Christmas but hairy and vaguely
wicked
the Empire's no thanks to an overdub see
from a new screen please an actual help
from one half of the honeymooners
are corny Julie's family will spend over
an hour horrifically groaning at each
other while you try to maintain your
last shred of sanity
[Music]
so melt your brain in Star Wars film so
awful
you'll never complain about the prequels
the latter tonight or sell Oh again
because no matter what Disney decides to
throw it is next there's no way it will
be as bad as Chuy's dad watching VR porn
in the middle of the living room why
just dream that oh no no there it is
that was real we are geez it off turn it
off story love it baby
at least Warwick Davis got paid no hairy
wizard fortunes
best I ever had magnificent Wilford
Brimley dropping the f-bomb in a TV
movie for children what Jefferson Malibu
Boog Carrie Fisher giving zero shits
lumpy Space Prince and yeah the wookie
Star Wars the first sellouts Wow Wow
weirdest thing about these movies it's
the first appearance of Boba Fett and
it's awesome I take it you have no love
of the Empire
I don't follow a friend
all they do is eat your mother know
you're we're third waves remember decant
I'm a potato head on a potato head farm
with my potato head family be potato
head strong as someone who has heard
people constantly complain about the
holiday special specifically the holiday
special is it is tough to get through
even when you're watching it for ironic
purpose and I've never seen weird any
footage of it the closest I've seen to
like weird Star Wars footage is going on
the Star Tours ride at Disneyland and
seeing like weird what are you doing
here even that's kind of cool as a ride
right yeah this is you know the
simulator so it makes up for it this is
just an honest trailer of this stuff and
I am genuinely surprised
it makes me rethink what they say here
at the end of it about you can't really
complain about the prequels and the last
Jedi and the solo spin-off now it makes
me rethink it cuz every time people are
like Disney's ruining Star Wars or the
prequels ruins our stories already
ruined itself a couple times look at
this whoa wait a minute this is before
Star Wars was given off or something
like that this is what Star Wars was
still introduced to the world and fresh
and ha I didn't know that the og cast
appeared in the holiday special yeah
well that's the thing I guess that's
reassuring in light of these you think
okay maybe the lackluster installments
that come out now will just fade into
obscurity like these have I'd heard that
there were these Ewok movies but I had
forgotten completely that they existed I
haven't seen you there of them the lack
of effect of curses are there for TV
yeah they're not get the full PNA
however from the people yeah there's
still around the time when Star Wars was
first introduced to us they were already
ruining Star Wars way long ago yeah yeah
I said I mean I I think I watched the
holiday special like late one night at
one of those morbid curiosity like let's
let's YouTube something and see if we
can get through it and like it even for
fun man that's a challenge that's a
weird weird special man Harrison Ford
McKnight knowing who Harrison Ford is
yeah how miserable you felt to be a part
of that you know oh yeah this this makes
me appreciate solo more I don't even
hate solo like I I'm on the spectrum
like it's fine it's cool it's fine it's
alright yeah yeah and that just depends
on where you as a viewer land because
some people might see stuff like this
that's like aggressively odd and
arguably very bad and be like this
upsets me more than something like solo
which is you know just SuperDuper okay
but on the flip side I can see why you
that middle road that ambivalence might
bum you out more either way it seems
this evident that the Star Wars
franchise has been through many peaks
and valleys over time and it didn't just
start with the prequels and it didn't
just start with solo or anything like
for the last Jedi or whatever I was
pretty surprised that this this has ever
made
this looks god-awful yeah and I mean
Chewie getting back to his family is so
hampered by the fact that for whatever
reason Chuy's endearing in the movies
and he's a kid his family's creepy in
there well thanks screen junkies for
introducing someone like me to what the
hell these things were you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation quick
tech notification bail move katsu